c'était l'évènement pour tous les
passionnés de vélo et de cyclotourisme
la 25e édition de la jean racine se
tenait dans la vallée de chevreuse le
week end du 29 et du 30 avril plus de
trois mille cyclistes de toute l'île de
france s'étaient donné rendez vous pour
des parcours à vélo en forêt ou sur
route
l'occasion de se retrouver en famille ou
entre amis
je n'ai aujourd'hui parce que mon
habitude de sortir mais tête avec les
amis puis c'est l'occasion de tous se
retrouver de se rassembler dans la
région alors combien de différents coins
de la france des parcours vtt de 17 à
120 kilomètres mais également un salon
avec des stands des ateliers des
exposants sous le signe cette année de
l'éco mobilité sur ce salon on trouve
beaucoup d'exposants beaucoup de marques
beaucoup de magasins aussi du coin de la
région d'avesnes chevreuse on trouve
aussi de l'andi loisir puisque nous on
souhaite faire la promotion de l'éco
mobilité du vélo danser dans ses grandes
lignes
que ce soit pour les gens valides que
pour les gens valides s'est pas
uniquement le vélo sportif ceci le vélo
loisirs donc le vélo parler au travail
le mélo pour aller à la piscine le vélo
aussi pour le travail solidarité aussi
avec un stand roulons solidaire où toute
la famille pourraient participer au
profit de l'institut pasteur sa
kilomètres ça fait 1 euros pour
l'association
donc j'aime bien en faire beaucoup de
kilomètres c'était aussi la possibilité
pour tous les jeunes de pratiquer en
toute sécurité
et d'oser des figures renversante